before
ladies and gentlemen thank you very much
for joining us today it's my pleasure to
introduce Secretary of Defense employee
Austin and chairman of the joint Jesus
staff General mark milley
secretary Austin will begin with some
brief comments followed by General
milley I will call on the reporters and
due to time and constraints I would ask
you please limit your followers with
that I turned over to secretary well
thanks Patrick good afternoon everyone
and thanks for joining us today
we've just concluded our ninth meeting
of the Ukraine defense contact group
I'd like to thank Ukrainian
minister of defense reznikov and his
team for once again joining us today
now
next week the world will Mark a grim
milestone
it will have been a year since Russia
invaded its peaceful neighbor
Ukraine
in our hearts
are with the families of
all the Ukrainian soldiers killed and
wounded
fighting to defend their country
their sovereignty and their fellow
citizens
and we mourn alongside Ukraine Ukrainian
civilians who have lost children
and parents
and loved ones
as Russia has deliberately attacked
civilian targets
Russia has inflicted a year of tragedy
and Terror
on Ukraine
with the people of Ukraine have inspired
the world
we deeply admire that the resilience of
the Ukrainian people
in their determination to defend their
territory
their sovereignty and their freedom
and nations of Goodwill have rallied
together to reject Putin's vision
of world chaos
of a world of chaos where tyrants can
trample borders and Conquer their
peaceful neighbors and break the rules
of War
and that's what this contact group
represents
together we have made clear that we will
support Ukraine's self-defense for the
Long Haul
and we will move out with the urgency at
the moment demands
earlier this month the United States
announced another round of security
assistance for Ukraine
we'll run out of announcement included
more ammunition for high Mars
it included 190 heavy heavy machine guns
to counter unmanned aerial systems from
Russia or or Iran
181 M rep vehicles in more than 2 000
anti-tank Munitions and other key
capabilities
we also added
1.75 billion dollars in Ukraine's
security assistance initiative funds
for critical air defense capabilities
including
County uas uas systems and more
and at today's contact group we joined
again with our valued allies and
partners
to make sure that Ukraine has what it
needs
when it needs
we continue to work together to provide
Ukraine with full combat credible
capabilities
and not just equipment
and that's why we discuss synchronizing
our donations into an integrated
training plan
you can see the importance of our
coordination and our common efforts to
meet Ukraine's needs for armor
among the members of this contact group
we have given Ukraine's Defenders
more than eight combat brigades
this includes major contributions from
the United States
Strikers and Bradleys and neighbor's
tanks
it includes the UK's donation of
Challenger tanks
in the contribution of Senator armed
Personnel armored personnel carriers
that Canada announced last month
it also includes the refurbished t-72
tanks that the United States the
Netherlands and a Czech Republic
are in a process of delivering
as well as Poland's latest donation of
t-72s
and it includes the important steps from
Germany
Poland Canada
Portugal
Spain
Norway Denmark and the Netherlands on
Leopard battle tanks
now we also heard today about
significant new air defense donations
that includes Italy and France which
jointly announced that they will provide
Ukraine with the samp T air defense
system
France also announced that it will work
with Australia
to ramp up 1.5 millimeter ammunition
production to support Ukraine
and finally let me also thank Norway
which just announced that it will
provide 7.5 billion euros in Military
and civilian assistance to Ukraine over
the coming five years
that's a very significant commitment now
all of these capabilities will continue
to be important for Ukraine's success on
the battlefield
but as I said last month in Ramstein
this isn't about one single capability
it's about delivering all the
capabilities that we promised
it's about integrating all these systems
together
it's about working with the ukrainians
to help them fight for their freedom
now we also had an important discussion
today on our ongoing work on
accountability
it's a priority for me
and my contact group colleagues to
ensure that our donations continue to be
used as intended and that we move
proactively to prevent arms
proliferation
and we will keep working with our
Ukrainian Partners to ensure that all
the equipment that we're providing
continues to reach the brave troops on
the front lines
now a year ago
Putin assumed that Ukraine was an easy
target
Putin assumed that Kiev would easily
fall
and Putin assumed that the world would
stand by
the Kremlin was wrong on every camp
over the past year Ukraine soldiers have
fought valiantly for their country
Ukraine's people have shown deep courage
in the face of Russian cruelty
and countries of Goodwill have rallied
to defend an open order of rules and
rights
together we seek a world where disputes
are resolved peacefully
where sovereignty is respected
where borders are honored
and where civilians are protected
those are the values of this contact
group
We Stand United in our support for
Ukraine's fight for freedom
and we will stand together
United and Resolute for as long as it
takes
and with that let me turn it over to
General Miller
thank you secretary Austin and uh thank
you for your leadership leading this
ninth successive contact group this is
an incredible level of effort by many
many countries it wouldn't be happening
without the leadership of secretary
Austin good afternoon everyone and let
me start by giving my condolences to the
people of turkey and Syria with the
tragic loss of life and suffering has
occurred because a recent earthquake
also suffering of the Ukrainian people
we are approaching the one-year
anniversary
of Russia's illegal invasion
of a Sovereign Nation Sovereign Nation
of Ukraine
and I want to thank the Ministers of
defense and the chiefs of defense that
we're here today
representing 54 countries
that continue to participate in this
group
the actions of those leaders over the
last year
have contributed substantially with real
effect on the battlefield
and they collectively have demonstrated
unwavering commitment
to the defense of Ukraine
and a special thank you to the Ukrainian
Ministry defense resnikov and his Deputy
Chad General moisture
who continued to display exceptional
leadership
and my friend General zaluzny who's on
the battlefield every day leading his
country's defense
10 days from now
is the one year anniversary
when Russia brutally illegally and in a
completely unprovoked way
invaded The Sovereign Nation of Ukraine
as the secretary just pointed out
Putin thought he could defeat Ukraine
quickly fracture the NATO alliance and
act with impunity
he was wrong
Ukraine remains free they remain
independent nato in this Coalition has
never been stronger
and Russia is now a global pariah and
the world remains inspired
by Ukrainian bravery and resilience in
short
Russia has lost
they've lost strategically
operationally and tactically
and they are paying an enormous price on
the battlefield
but until Putin ends his war of choice
the International Community will
continue to support Ukraine with the
equipment and capabilities it needs to
defend itself
through this group we are collectively
supporting Ukraine's ability to defend
its territory protect its citizens and
liberate their occupied areas
in the face of a barbaric Russian
invasion
ukrainians remain resilient
the nation of Ukraine is United for one
single purpose to expel the Russian
forces from their territory and to
defend themselves
for Ukraine this is not a war of
aggression it is a war of Defense
for Russia it is a war of aggression
the Russian military has paid tremendous
costs in their war of aggression
and now they've resorted to send in
conscripts and prisoners to imminent
death
in recent months the group would gather
here today pledged to provide
significant quantities of Battlefield
capabilities
tanks air defense and munitions
11 countries have pledged tanks 22 have
pledged infantry fighting Vehicles 16
pleased artillery ammunitions and nine
more pledged Air Defense Artillery the
group is focused focused on delivering
the capabilities committed and
efficiently providing the training the
spare parts the sustainment logistics
necessary
for the Full Employment of these systems
training maintaining and sustaining
Ukraine's remains key
for Ukraine to prevail
throughout this war Ukraine has shown
incredible resourcefulness and how they
integrate varied capabilities to adapt
the changing dynamics of this
battlefield
ukrainians have combined unbreakable
will with Innovative tactics and
empowered their leaders to liberate
their own country
Russia on contrast is waging a very
costly war of attrition
well Ukraine is effectively leveraging
their asymmetric advantages in order to
defend itself
and the most important asymmetric
Advantage they have is courage
resilience and tactical skill
this war is extremely dynamic
and Ukraine today is fighting while
training and evolving for future
operations
Ukraine will integrate recent
commitments of armored vehicles infantry
fighting vehicles and tanks with fires
to achieve the effect of synchronized
ground maneuvers
well Russia has wages War for far too
long they will not Outlast the Ukrainian
people nor the group of allies and
partners that met today
the purpose for the United States and
allies
as said by our political leadership
is very simple
it's to uphold the rules based
International order in order that
rejects the idea that big strong
powerful Nations can attack other
smaller countries that borders shall not
change just by the use of aggressive
military force this is the very
underlying founding principle of the
United Nations
at the end of World War II Ukraine does
not stand alone
54 countries met today to ensure that
Ukraine can defend itself and the
principles that guide International
conduct and those principles will be
upheld
we will remain a unified Coalition we
will continue to uphold the values of
sovereignty and freedom and will
continue to support Ukraine
thank you and I welcome your questions
secretary Austin
um you said earlier this is a crucial
moment for Ukraine and that the Allies
need to get air defenses and Munitions
into Ukraine now what are you seeing
from Russia that makes this moment
different and the NATO Secretary General
has already warned that Ukraine is
burning through Munitions faster than
the rate that the Allies can supply it
will you at some point need to ask
Ukraine to do more with less
and then for chairman Millie
did one of the missiles fired at the
Lake Huron object Miss
and if so what happened to that missile
and if so does that change your risk
calculus for shooting down objects over
U.S soil are you starting to develop
Alternatives if if and when you detect
the next object
yeah where we are thanks Tara
in terms of where we are in the fight
what we see what we've seen over the
last several months
uh
she is a contested Battlefield
we see a lot of activity in in the bach
mood area which is where Russia is is
focusing most of its effort we see
Russia uh
introducing a number of uh new troops to
the battlefield many of those troops are
ill-trained and and
ill-equipped and so their casualty rate
has been really high
um
what Ukraine wants to do in the you know
at the first possible moment is to
establish or create a momentum and uh in
in establish uh conditions on a
battlefield that continue to be in its
favor and so well we expect to see them
conduct an offensive uh sometime in the
spring and because of that you know we
are we all the partners in the in the
Ukraine defense contact group
have been working hard to ensure that
they have the armored capability the
fires the sustainment to be able to be
effective in creating the effects on the
battlefield that they want to create and
so
we believe that there'll be a window of
opportunity for them to exercise
initiative and then change
or continue to to uh
create the the right conditions on the
battlefield here
in terms of Munitions this has been a
tough fight throughout and we've been uh
Ukraine has been at this for a year and
so they have used a lot of artillery
ammunition we're going to do everything
we can working with our International
Partners to ensure that we give them as
much uh ammunition as quickly as as
possible and that we'll do everything we
can to sustain our efforts here as well
um we are working to uh with the
Ukrainian soldiers in various places
throughout Europe uh to emphasize
additional training on maneuver so that
uh as they Place more emphasis on a
maneuver and shaping the battlefield
with fires and that maneuvering there's
a good chance that they'll require less
uh less artillery Munitions but that's
left to be seen so we're going to do
everything we can to make sure that they
have what they need to be successful and
that's what we continue to emphasize
here in the Ukraine defense contact
group and uh and we think the training
will pay additional dividends as well
so tear on the uh balloon shot yes uh
first shot missed on the fourth balloon
so we're talking about the balloon that
was uh downed over Lake Huron uh the
first blue in the Chinese Spike balloon
uh that went down over the Atlantic and
the South Carolina coast that was that
shot hit the second one over uh Alaska
on the North coast of Alaska that one
hit uh the third one in that landed in
the Yukon that one hit uh on the fourth
one over Lake Huron first shot missed a
second shot hit so the most important
thing for the American Military is to
protect the American people so we
evaluate the risk we evaluate the risk
of the balloons themselves are they a
kinetic thread or not yes no are they an
intelligence threat are they a threat to
civil aviation all those things we go
through very very carefully we determine
what the debris field is likely to be
with one of these platforms uh landing
on the Earth's surface or in the water
so we go to Great Lanes to make sure
that the air space is clear and the
backdrop is clear out to the max
effective range of the missile and in
this case the missiles land or the
missile landed harmlessly in the Water
of Lake Huron we so we tracked it all
the way down and we made sure that the
airspace was clear of any commercial
civilian or recreational traffic we do
the same thing for the maritime space so
we're very very deliberate in our
planning North County does that along
with the pilots themselves so we're very
very careful to make sure that those
shots are in fact safe and that's the
guidance from the president shoot it
down to make sure we minimize collateral
damage and we preserve the safety of the
American people
are you confirming the other
I'll just use the word object that's
what everyone's using
well we'll see when I'm recovered yet as
you know the number two three and four
not recovered yet number one we are
recovering and getting a lot of stuff
off that but uh two three and four not
yet recover they're very difficult
terrain uh the the second one off coast
of Alaska is uh that's up in uh in in
some really really difficult train in
the arctic circle with very very low
temperatures in the minus 40s the second
one is in the color in the Canadian
Rockies in Yukon very difficult to get
that one and the third one is in uh in
Lake Huron it probably a couple hundred
feet depth so we'll get them eventually
but it's going to take some time to
recover those
let's go to dimitro you perform
thank you for your National research and
see if you grant meters to Mr secretary
was the question of the plane supplies I
mean Comet Jets applies to Ukraine was
discussed or not and what kind of
security circumstances should be created
inside Ukraine to deploy a new type of
aircrafts of such kind does it mean that
that is possible after the integrated
air defense system is created and to
General Millie if I may uh what is your
risk assessment for a supply routes of
the delivery of Western Equipment and
ammunition to Ukraine and how it could
be made more secure thank you
so an issue of aircraft I don't have any
announcements to make on aircraft today
we're going to continue to work with
Ukraine to address Ukraine's most
pressing needs again you know they're
contemplating an offensive in in the
spring and that's just weeks away and so
we have a lot to get done so if you
think about the numbers of systems that
we're bringing together
Bradley's Strikers
Martyrs CB 90s 113s
all right
artillery in the list goes on and on
it's a Monumental task to bring all
those systems together and get the
troops trained on those platforms and
make sure we have sustainment for that
for for all of those systems and get
those systems into the fight so that's
that's really the focus of our our of
our conversation today
so dimitro lines of communication in
Warfare and combat are always subject to
enemy attack no no different here and
the lines of communication that stretch
through the Western portions of Ukraine
are subject to Russian attack attack
from the air attack from artillery
attacking Special Operations Force Etc
so the key to ensure that the the
supplies get through maintain good
operational security uh vary your times
don't set patterns take different routes
and make sure you disperse uh your Force
so you have small Penny packets as
opposed to one large massive conduit the
security from the Polish border or any
other border remaining border anywhere
that security is uh part of the security
plan for the Ukrainian Armed Forces they
picked the stuff up and they do that
they practice all the good tactics
techniques and procedures that I just
described I would say it's not without
risk but it's moderate it's been
successful so far to get through
let's go to Alicia Schwartz Financial
Times
first for secretary Austin we've heard
from Western officials that Russia's Air
Force is well intact and that the
Russians are preparing to launch an air
campaign as its land forces are depleted
where is Russia amassing aircraft ahead
of the offensive how soon could this
begin has this hastened the need to
provide air defense to Ukraine and has
enough assistance been provided so that
Ukraine is ready to defense against it
and then for chairman Millie does Russia
have the right equipment to pose a
threat to the ukrainians and
breakthrough in the donbath and
separately but relatedly is Ukraine
going to get enough equipment in enough
time and have a big enough force on the
ground to be able to have a serious
counter-offensive
uh thanks Alicia in terms of whether or
not Russia is
massing its aircraft for some massive
aerial attack we don't currently see
that we do know that Russia has a
substantial number of aircraft in its
inventory and a lot of capability left
that's why we've emphasized that you
know we need to do everything that we
can to get Ukraine as much air defense
capability as we possibly can and
recently you've seen us step up and
offer Patriots you've seen other
countries come forward with sampte and
in rst but it's not enough and we're
going to keep pushing until we we get
more because that threat is is out there
but again we many countries have stepped
up to the plate thus far
our effort currently is to get this
these capabilities into country as
quickly as we can and then integrate
those capabilities so we have truly have
an integrated error and missile defense
capability
and I would add that Ukraine's done a
credible job of uh of intercepting a lot
of the uh the rockets and missiles that
have been launched by by Russia in the
in those recent attacks but again we
want to make sure that they have the
ability to protect themselves uh going
forward any event that Russia tries to
introduce its Air Force into this fight
they haven't done so thus far because
Ukraine's air defenses have been pretty
gaster and effective as you know
so Felicia on on whether or not the
Russians have the capability and
Equipment Etc to continue the attack in
the Don boss they are affecting the
donbos right now their progress is slow
it's a war of attrition they're taking
heavy cassidies their leadership and
morale is not great and they're
struggling mightily however they do have
numbers uh and as you know uh President
Putin did a call up of several hundred
thousand uh and those folks have been
arriving on the battlefield so they do
have numbers and whether or not they're
successful in pressing the fight that
remains to be seen but that fight has
been going on uh and it's a slow
grinding Battle of attrition in that in
that general area for the ukrainians I
don't want to project forward what
ukrainians may or may not do as you know
from this particular conference here we
are plusing that book with a significant
amount of capabilities with ground
maneuver artillery Etc uh what they do
with that uh that'll be up to the
ukrainians in the coming weeks and
months we have time for one more let's
go to Marcus price
one question to secretary Austin uh
about the stands of the U.S when it
comes to delivery of uh fighter jets and
the President Biden said no to the
delivery of F-16 Also earlier in the
conflict when Poland offered to deliver
mid-29 via Ramstein to Ukraine I think
the U.S stocked it has this position uh
evolved do you encourage countries to do
so if they want to or do you assess the
risk is too high so what is the U.S
position on other countries delivering
fighter jets and to Chairman Millie um
the Russian offensive we're seeing what
do you see so far is this very serious
is it different than what we saw in the
past and do you have any intelligence
whether we see in we are going to see
another attempt of the Russian forces to
capture Kiev thank you
thank you thanks Marcus for the record
um
with respect to any kind of aircraft
being provided by Poland the United
States never stopped Poland from do from
providing anything
uh a decision to provide something is a
is a
that's the
you know the
decision made that will be a decision
made by the Leisure of that country
that's certainly not something that we
can or will dictate
in terms of whether or not uh we're
going to provide f-16s as I said earlier
I don't have any announcements to make
and I don't have anything to uh to add
to what what our president said earlier
so and I'll just leave it at that
and uh Marcus on the issue of the
Russian offensive this this offensive
that you see ongoing right now in the
Box generally in the Bachman area uh you
know from from car keep all the way down
uh to kirtasan the front line is quite
stable even though very violent a lot of
fighting it's relatively stable most of
the uh Dynamic movement back and forth
is in generally in the vicinity of
buckmouth the ukrainians are holding uh
they're fighting the defense the
Russians primarily the Wagner are
attacking but there's a what what I
would describe it as is a a really uh a
very significant grinding Battle of
attrition with very high casualties
especially on the Russian side there's
no fancy Arts of maneuver going on here
this is frontal attacks wave attacks
lots of artillery with extremely high
levels of casualties in that particular
area and how long that will last is
difficult to say actually it's been
going on for weeks and I think it'll
continue to go on until the uh until the
either the Russians culminate uh I don't
think the ukrainians would just collapse
or fold I think they're going to
continue to fight so that